der eu vertrag mit astrazeneca er liegt
jetzt hier bei uns im studio und zwar
vor unseren kollegen chefreporter peter
tiede peter wie schlecht ist dieser
vertrag verhandelt worden
also dieser vertrag so schlecht
behandelt worden dass sich die juso
dahinter verstecken müsste ein
peinliches stückchen verhandlungs
politik immer auf details ein was genau
fällt ihr auf diesen vertrag auf was
genau sind die punkte wurde sagt da
konnte ich nur noch kopfschütteln also
es gibt ja den streit zwischen der
eu-kommission und dem und dem konzern
astrazeneca und der chef von astrazeneca
hat ja gesagt ist ein best efforts
vertrag so heißt das darin verpflichtet
man sich nur nach besten möglichkeiten
zu liefern und zu produzieren dass das
einmal angucken wie achim sie noch
darauf 18 mal und lasst es uns in einer
passage mal anschauen
diese best effort klausel die du dann
ernst das heißt wir können das gerade
lesen die maßnahmen und das maß an
anstrengungen die an unternehmen in
vergleichbarer größe wie astrazeneca
durchführen oder nutzen würde um eine
globale pandemie zu beenden da werden
jetzt noch nicht so richtig schlau draus
was heißt das genau was heißt best
effort das wort bedeutet das mandat
besten möglichkeiten also dass man sein
bestes gibt zeugnis er hat sich stets
bemüht und dass man dann sagen kann er
hat sich ja bemüht also wir bemühen uns
so gut wie möglich sie zu beliefern
da werden wir gleich noch experten hören
die das komplett verflogen 18 mal taucht
das auffinden vertrag hast wo 18 mal bis
er wird also nach besten möglichkeiten
sind unverbindlich zu wenig klar also
wachs reich wär ja dann das ist nichts
das ist nichts was hat die eu
kommissionspräsidenten frau von der
leyen heute morgen noch im
deutschlandradio getönt wir wollen
wissen was dann videos wir wollen unsere
lieferungen haben wir haben feste
liefermengen nichts gar nichts
es ist butterweich das ist kein vertrag
das ist kein harter vertrag da hat man
offensichtlich nicht wirklich gewusst
was man macht gefährlich wird jetzt
dieser vertrag für ursula von der leyen
ganz schön gefährlich also weit das kann
man so nicht das kann man so nicht
stehen lassen dies auf dem dieser von
konzern losgegangen
der liefert zudem liefert zu konditionen
zum selbstkostenpreis also das ist jetzt
nicht als genie kann macht damit jetzt
nicht milliarden sondern die liefern zum
selbstkostenpreis in die eu und
natürlich die haben produktionsausfälle
und die
von busunternehmen bevor zu
großbritannien hat aber vorher bestellt
und auch größere mengen das ist der
bessere kunden die wir sind zu spät
gekommen und wir wollen jetzt am
lautesten weil wir das später wir später
dran sind und diesen vertrag darf die eu
darf man in europa parlament dürfen die
mitgliedstaaten und dürfen vor allem die
bürger so nicht auf sich sitzen da sind
das ist eine frechheit für die
europäischen bürger eine frechheit für
uns alle sagst du peter jetzt gibt es
viel mehr nachrichten noch um diesen
konzern astrazeneca den glaube ich die
wenigsten von uns bis vor wenigen wochen
überhaupt kanten jetzt ist dieser
impfstoff seit wenigen minuten muss man
sagen in der eu offiziell zugelassen
gute nachricht gleichzeitig die
schlechte nachricht nur für unter
65-jährige dh ist das jetzt gut für die
jüngeren weil die dann mit astrazeneca
früher geimpft werden oder was bedeutet
das also die nachricht ist noch nicht
komplett also wir wissen nur dass die
dass die ehemals die europäische
zulassungsbehörde zu knapp 18 und nach
oben offen das ist die überraschung
heute bei ursprünglich davon ausgegangen
von aufgrund der etwas dünnen datenlage
wir haben gerade hinter damals gehört
von der frau von der stiko die datenlage
über 65 war dünn und das ist jetzt noch
offen wie in deutschland zugelassen wird
weil wir werden eine eigene verordnung
darüber kriegen da gibt es die stiko die
ständige impfkommission die gibt heute
noch jetzt irgendwann wird jeden moment
halt erwartet dass die ihre empfehlung
abgibt und daraus macht der
gesundheitsminister an eine verordnung
und da wird dann drin stehen ob der in
deutschland auch für über 65-jährige
verimpft werden darf oder ab 65 sind
zugelassen wäre dann nur bis 64 jahre
und das ist noch offen das ist die
spannende frage dieses amt bis jetzt
noch ungeklärt ob in deutschland
tatsächlich dann der auch für ältere und
werden kann wenn nicht dann heißt das
auf seine frage zurückzukommen dann wird
es für über 80 jährige die jetzt dran
werden schwieriger da wird ein bisschen
länger dauern für andere wie
medizinpersonal und vor erkrankte unter
unter 65 also leute mit herzinsuffizienz
mit mit transplantations- organ und mit
anderen sachen die gern früher dran
vor allem ältere zuschauer haben wir
heute mal gefragt was sie zu diesen
ganzen verzögerungen hin und her lasche
verträge usw dem langsamen impfen zu
sagen haben meine mutter ist über 80
leider heißt immer wieder es
gibt keinen impfstoff es gibt keine
termine jetzt sollte diesen neuen
impfstoff geben der leider nur bis
menschen bis 560 geeignet ist und die
politiker eigentlich phasen total
versagen der regierung zu dem thema
astra zenica und der 65 das ist nicht
das richtige system wenn wir werden alle
froh wenn wir uns endlich mal wieder
frei bewegen können und diese zulassung
blöd sind das muss auch irgendwann mal
aufhören dass bei uns andere länder vor
dem start der bundesregierung muss ich
ganz einfach sagen die leute versagen
was sehr spannend von sich gibt das ist
unglaublich jedem normalen firma würde
der man lange vor der tür stehen wo sich
einen neuen job suchen müssen
also wir sehen viele ältere menschen
sind empört darüber wie langsam es voran
geht und dass sie keinen impftermin
bekommen
bitter jetzt als bei senica
möglicherweise nicht zugelassen für
menschen über 65 das warten wir jetzt
noch ab aber wie würde das die im freien
folge beeinflussen sollte es so kommen
dass eben nur menschen unter 65 mit
diesem impfstoff geimpft werden können
dann werden die leute unter 65 früher
dran kommen und zwar nach ganz klar ein
kind kriterien die sind dann in einer
voll einer eigentlich folgenden
risikogruppe dran das sind die vier
erkrankten und unter 65 das ist zum
beispiel medizinisches personal das
bisher noch nicht in der flieger war und
noch nicht geboren ist und das können
dann auch polizisten und auch die
feuerwehrleute seien also unten gibt's
eine beschleunigung oben werden wir
etwas langsamer die gute nachricht ist
ja noch dass wir ab ende märz wenn es so
weitergeht doch noch mehr impfstoff hat
dann auf dem markt haben werden und dann
könnten wir aus diesem wirklich wirklich
bittere not stand die welt erfahren
müssen als industrienationen dann sind
wir einigermaßen raus aber jetzt würde
ich noch harte zeiten bittere zeiten
karge zeiten
danke bild chefreporter und mittlerweile
impfstoff-experte bietet wieder mit dem
vertrag der eu mit astrazeneca vor sich
den duo peter eine frechheit hier danke
für das gespräch
wir sind bild und wir liefern dir deine
news auf youtube zum nächsten video
kommst du hier
und vergiss bitte nicht unseren kanal zu
abonnieren